speaking of which today you can
experience The Taste the smells and the
style of Africa at a Freak Fest Las
Vegas it is the fourth year and today is
also their Flagship fundraising event so
let's go out live we've got Candace
Charles joining us to talk about the
celebration live in front of our
fabulous sign
good morning you took a morning folks
Clark County is really doing it up for
this Festival the welcome to Fabulous
Las Vegas sign is now black green red
gold and orange honoring the festival as
well as highlighting the 55 African
countries it really is quite a sight to
see it's really beautiful and it's a
nice way to introduce the community back
to this amazing Festival another
three-day arts and culture Festival
continues today at Sunset Park offering
the community as John mentioned the
taste smells and sights of Africa dozens
of businesses and vendors will line the
park with booths selling everything from
African clothes to food and the wheat
culminates in a Gala at the convention
center and performances by some of the
hottest African musicians
we bring different ethnicities together
to showcase the rich culture and the
diversity of our County but also lifting
up business lifting up uh economic
incentives is also as well as
opportunities that we have here within
Clark County
and tonight you get the chance to join
in on lifting up local African
businesses at the Africa Fest Market at
Sunset Park at five now as we mentioned
is their Flagship fundraising event it
is free to the public but the gala
that's happening on Saturday well of
course you got to get tickets for that
and of course got you covered with all
of those details so go to our website
8newsnow.com for those details Sherry I
think that I'm ready I got my colors one
ready to go I think it'll be cool to
stop by and maybe try some of the food
out what do you think oh I think so too
I think it's going to be wonderful
you're all dressed for the occasion
Candace looked beautiful and red this
morning